foreign
Orlando Florida what's up Alex
hey Dr John how are you sir I'm good man
how about you
doing wonderful beautiful day here in
sunshine Florida I can't complain that's
awesome it's a stunning day here in
Nashville it's beautiful in Tennessee
what's up wonderful hey how can I help
guide my parents more specifically my
dad
two smoke-free way of living
foreign
that's tough man
that's real how old is he it is my my
dad's a 66 and uh my mom's 71 and my dad
just had a heart attack a few weeks ago
yeah
the reason why I reach out to you is
because
um you know he he spent two days in the
hospital and as soon as he came out of
the hospital you know I called to follow
up with my mom that night and I talked
to her and and uh you know I said you
know is he is he still smoking and she
first says to me no he's not and I said
mom come on what's going on she said
well he he did just just one time just
one cigarette just three times you know
just really trying to justify it
and my grandparents died early and you
know I just we have a son of of our own
and I want my dad to be around and I
want my parents to be Rhonda to even get
older have you looked him in the eye and
told him those exact words
I have not I'm terrified to do it that's
it
I'm gonna tell you right now
um you've probably heard me say this on
this show not by your hand but in your
lap
here's what I mean by that there's lots
of problems historically that have
happened that I played no part in
but they're still here in my culture and
I gotta deal with it right or sometimes
your house may flood because your
neighbor left the water on at at some
point doesn't matter who left the water
on it's flooded my house I gotta deal
with it okay
you didn't cause this you didn't this
has nothing to do with anything you've
done
but you found yourself in a position
where you can either be terrified having
this conversation I promise you
you won't sleep for the rest of your
life
if or when your dad does pass away and
you don't have this conversation
right so you didn't cause it but it's a
conversation you have to have if nothing
else just so you can have some peace
when when he actually
heads up
right so uh do you all live in the same
neighborhood you all live far away
he lives in uh in Texas okay
um
but they're coming to visit us very soon
he actually here's another kicker for
you Dr John is he actually wants to help
us build a fence in our house
in the month of June in Florida
have you ever heard of
the the delusional male my dad is one of
the hardest working guys you'll ever
meet in your life he actually had a
heart attack after helping people in his
neighborhood in his area by chopping
wood for eight hours to ten hours on end
yes I got a buddy one of my best friends
in the world is Dad's in his 90s and uh
he just got put on hospice as terminal
cancer said he doesn't want to go
through all the rigamaru and the hospice
nurse showed up for the first time and
she couldn't find him and he was
planting rose bushes in the backyard in
Texas and she was like well and here's
the deal at some point I'm not going to
take that from you
like what's the alternative you just sit
on the couch you'll die fast right it's
I'm not going to take that from
somebody's wired that way your dad's 66
not 93.
as 30 years
true that's your son being too too uh
two kids into his life
see what I'm saying
yeah
um
man I can preach really big right now
I would have a hard time not getting on
an airplane and flying to Texas to look
my dad in the eye in his environment
if he's going to be there in a month
then that's up to you
you always run the risk of these kind of
conversations of him packing up and
going home and it's different when you
can take off and leave
right
um but it may be a conversation that you
want to have before he comes and stays
with you it's a conversation that has to
be done face to face and I'd recommend
writing a letter and reading it to him
because it's just gonna be tough to get
through if you just want to wait that's
a great idea
and it would start with it's just hard
enough to talk to you about it no yeah
it's I mean
um
if you guys man if you have a good dad
like you
my dad lost his dad at 93 or 94. and he
told me my dad was in his late late 60s
early 70s and he said it was unmooring
that was the exact same age as me when
when his dad passed exact same age I am
now I think that's how you start the
letter
when's the last time you looked your dad
now and told him these words I love you
um the last time he visited me okay so
y'all say that regularly yes yes sir
okay we grew up uh I grew up very close
to both my parents
um more specifically my dad and they
were always in my life every sport every
all through college all through
everything so okay great parents
um I think that's where you start ma'am
so it sounds like what's hard about this
is less about your dad's going to get
mad and kick you out and more hard like
this means you've got to you've got
you're coming to terms with the fact
that your dad's not gonna live forever
correct
yeah that's a different conversation
that's one about Grace and love and
I want you to be here for every second
not about power and move you see what
I'm saying this is a different country
correct absolutely correct so I'll tell
you this will be one of the hardest
things you ever do but it will be one of
the most beautiful things that
um
you will experience in your life even if
it goes awful it will be beautiful
because you got to look the most
important man in the entire world to you
in the eye and say I love you and I love
you this much
please stop please be around here a
little bit longer
and if you want to play dirty you want
to play dirty
which hey when it comes to saving lives
I'm all about it
you can slide a photograph that you've
had printed off like at Walgreens of you
and your son
and you can say if not for you for us
in in counseling when we have somebody
who yells at their kid
one of the things we will do sometimes
is ask them to get a picture
of their child one of their children
and every time they're about to scream
and yell
pull that picture up and look at it and
say
um
I care so little about you I'm about to
let your mama have it
or we'll ask them to carry a picture of
their stepmom or their stepfather who is
abusive and they'll pull that picture
out and say hey I care more about
modeling what you did than my little
voice feelings I'm about to do what you
taught me and literally the behavior
goes away
and so that's cheating it's not cool
it's plain dirty but in this situation I
I mean I'm all for it I would pull out
every stop I have but to stop being
you're not trying to convince some
bullheaded [__] that won't listen to
you and it's been blowing you off your
whole life
you're trying to tell a man
who's a great guy
I love you this much
correct yeah
dude he's lucky to have you man
I'm not gonna have both of them you're a
hell of a son man
thank you
how old's your little one
he's uh just turned 13. hmm
if you want to play super super dirty
you can have him write a note too
I'm gonna get him I want to give them
too much involved and all that okay
gonna tell you something bananas
what's up he's involved
it's true it's true
and even if nothing else the opportunity
for him to write a letter to a Granddad
just to say hey I got scared and I love
you
don't have to mention the smoking but
just giving him an opportunity
would be a pretty neat moment
be a pretty cool man yeah
I appreciate that a lot because of this
conversation my son's 13 and my dad came
and visited us this past weekend and
just took off I'm gonna have my son
write my dad a letter uh this week too
in honor of Alex thank you for inspiring
me to do this because it'll be an
important moment for my son too
thank you Dr John you're awesome my
brother hey uh let me know how that
conversation goes Alex
um
I'd love to share how that went and if
you want to be super dope super Brave uh
I'd love for you to come back on the
show and read that letter to our
audience there's probably zero to uh
less than zero chance that you that your
dad listens to us so
um if you do want to give an example to
our listeners of uh your fellow
delonites what a letter like this might
look like that would be incredible I
would really uh it'd be an honor but
thank you for your bravery go call your
old man and tell them that you love him
and you want to be him to be around for
another 20 or 30 years